indeed another one of the features that
all these philosophies touch on or deal
with is a kind of goal in life something
called
ataraxia which means something like
absence of disturbance or trouble
perhaps Loosely translatable to
something like
contentment sometimes it's translated as
happiness but that doesn't quite do it
justice so how does one achieve this
state of ataraxia and connected to this
what is the nature of a good life what
is it that is good at all good being
defined here as something that is
desirable for its own sake for the
epicureans the answer was pretty simple
the highest good in life is pleasure
pleasure is the only thing that is
valuable in this world since they were
materialists this seemed a pretty
obvious
conclusion but it isn't Hedonism in the
more crude sense the ideas of epicurus
are actually a lot more nuanced than
that he